And the answer is the first three.
This last one doesn't make any sense,
because Yuv must be non-negative.
If u were in B, and Y were in A,
then Yuv would be 0,
which shouldn't count towards
our objective function.
One thing to notice immediately
about this program is that
because the capacities are all positive,
the Yuvs will be as small as possible.
Next, the parallelism between
these equations suggest
that we think of, ys,
being a variable fixed as 1,
and yt, be a variable here, fixed as 0.
All of these edge variables then
only need be greater than zero when
the left hand variable over here is
one and the right hand one is zero.
This immediately suggests that variables
with a single sub script indicate
which side of the partition in the s-t
cut the corresponding vertex is on.
If they differ in the right direction.
Then Yuv must be one,
it's an edge cut by the cut and
the capacity of that edge counts
towards the objective function.
The first three points follow
from this realization.